Diana Redding has a large family but
many of them live abroad it means she's
facing Christmas on her own well I'd
have been very down about it because
um I think when one gets older and um
feeling now
any day could be my last or my last
Christmas you you don't want to think
that but you know it's true and I just
wanted the family to be together so much
I think yes I will feel sad so I just
try and think of happy times
but at the age of 80 she's had to grow
used to being alone sometimes a week can
go by with only her dog for company my
Corazon it means life at her home in
Litchfield can be very lonely it has
affected me and it takes you into Dark
Places
you go down to a level
where you sort of just existing and you
don't you don't even realize it and now
there's the expensive going out
and so everything costs
it's the same for many thousands of
others according to age UK 1.3 million
older people expect to feel lonely this
Christmas
2.7 million that's about a quarter of
older people so they can't afford to go
out as much and 600 000 around 1 in 20
older people are facing Christmas
without talking to anyone hello it's why
staff and volunteers at this charity in
Tamworth will be working on Christmas
Day their phone calls are the only
contact many older people have with the
outside world staff build up that
relationship and trust with the person
and able to pick up on things so if
they're feeling down or have a need of
any additional help and support we're
able to provide that but also it's just
that kind of
um being there for somebody and knowing
that somebody's thinking of them and
that may be all some older people have
to look forward to a Christmas they
can't hope to enjoy but just endure
Becky Johnson Sky News Litchfield